good morning everyone dear IL this
morning we paid tribute to the lives of
two people who have been brutally taken
away by by blind hatred Belgium offers
again its sincere condolences to um to
the families to the Friends of the two
people who died and to the whole
population of of Sweden we recognize how
this terrorist attack has profoundly
shaken our society your Society but also
Belgian Belgian Society what happened
really affects our citizens daily
lives you should know that you can uh
you can always count on us and that the
Swedish population can always count on
the sympathy of of us belgians and that
we will continue you working away
working together it is quite clear that
in this fight in this fight against
extremism We Stand shoulder toh
shoulder it is a fight for freedom for
democracy in essence it's a fight for
for respect respect between human beings
respect for the fact that we can have
different ideas that we can have
discussions about our ideas but it can
never lead to violence and definitely
never lead to the violence that we have
seen this fight is not an easy one we
have seen this over the past years it is
a fight that we must win and I want to
be clear it is a fight that we will win
and we will win it
together it is also clear that more
united European action is needed to work
on the root
causes of what we have seen happening
here over the past days and that is why
dear Ursula I'm extremely happy to have
you here president of European
commission extremely happy to have you
here on our side of um two government
leaders of uh of member
states in the case of this terrorist
attack we cannot look back from the fact
that uh one of the decisive elements of
what happened here a few days ago is a
fact that the person who committed this
was a person coming from illegal
migration and this is something that uh
we need to tackle and we can only tackle
this if we do this in a coordinated way
to me there are two Dimensions which we
need to tackle in a coordinated way
first of all is a better protection of
our external
borders secondly and I would say equally
important is a more Resolute and a more
coordinated return policy for people who
are end of the migration
procedures now Belgian is uh committed
more than ever to do its part and as you
know we will be uh president of the
European uh rotating president of the
European Council from uh from next year
on bringing the European Asylum and
migration pack to a successful end is uh
is our highest priority and and we see
that it is evolving in the right
direction ction for the moment we do not
see major roadblocks and it is really a
priority for us to bring that to an
end we know that we can count on the
support of the member states and uh and
we will continue working together with
all of the member states and bringing
that to a good end and we know that we
have the full support of Sweden and Des
in this to bring this European migration
pact uh together and that European
migration pack should stand for better
border controls but also for the
coordinated European return
policy Sweden and Belgium are
shoulder-to-shoulder in the same in the
same fight and and dear UL I really
would like to thank you and and we've
been uh in close contact over the past
days um in in dramatic circumstances in
in difficult circumstances it really
work together very well on on our level
and also our services I think were
really seamlessly working together and
there UL I would like to uh to thank you
for for your support and your
willingness to to be present here uh
today
I'm convinced that uh if we join hands
in Europe we can make the immigration
and Asylum system a better system and
I'm convinced that we can make it more
Humane and that we can also make it more
just and we are fully committed in uh in
coming to a successful end to that
endeavor and I'm convinced that we will
do that and we will do it together the R
thank you so much I could be I could be
so brief to just say I I agree with
everything you said Alexander I would
Echo every every word of it and thank
you so much for good cooperation thanks
for your very rapid um telephone call
and our telephone calls during these
days I think it gives a lot of U trust
to our agencies and our um populations
as well that we cooperate so well in
very U tragic circumstances we don't
have all the answers yet as we all know
but I would like to say just a few
things that first of all for Sweden
there is it seems to be a terrorist
attack aimed at Sweden and that Swedish
citizens just because of being swed of
course
that's that's a tragedy in itself um my
thoughts are for today of course with
the innocent swedes that have been
killed and injured and there uh beloved
ones I will try to meet uh the injured
person later this afternoon
um uh thanks also for the commemoration
that we had earlier today it is
obviously difficult to take in the scope
of the consequences of this um terrorist
attack and previous attacks of of a
similar
kind
um they want to scare us obviously they
they refuse to accept our way of living
they refuse to accept the values we we
share and the values we we
um we cherish
um they hate the open opportunities or
the open Society where you can actually
have friendly and peaceful discussions
also about very sensitive and difficult
topics uh and I fully understand that
many sweds right now are are scared they
are angry they are frustrated they are
looking for answers to questions we yet
don't have uh have and questions
we not are not used to to to be forced
to ask ourselves but I have two similar
conclusions as um as Alexander uh the
first is actually protecting our
societies standing up and sticking to
our values that is key we do not give up
our values we are not the ones that
should change our way of living we are
firm on that but being firm on Democracy
on Tolerance on openness and freedom
also requires us to be firm on security
when they do like this we raise our
security uh measures to be able to
protect the free and open Society that's
key and the second key is obviously also
that we need to be able to protect our
borders we need to know who is in
Sweden are they here legally or
illegally if they are not here in a
legal way they are obliged to leave the
country we need to protect our European
borders as we have discussed quite
frequently the last European councils if
we are not able to protect our common
borders we will not be able to uphold
the the the free movement within Europe
these are extremely important uh parts
of what it is be to to being a European
community so um we stick to our values
we raise the the our security uh
measures and we will U be able to to
defeat these people thank you so much
thank you thank you very much Alexander
it was important for me to be here today
after this terror attack that hit the
capital of Europe and I thank prime
minister de Crow and Prime Minister
Christen for having invited
me my condolences go to the families and
friends of the
victims victims of a targeted and heus
terror
attack and Olf you spoke about
hate um this attack was motivated by
hate there's no place and zero tolerance
for hate in
Europe we see these days that hate
speech is spreading extremely fast
through social media like
wildfire hate speech has real life
consequences but we have now the tools
to fight it
online thanks to our DSA the Digital
Services
act we are able to oblige the platforms
to take hate speech and terrorist
content
down we know that hate speech leads to
Terror teror
acts putting in danger the security of
our Citizens Independent of their faith
nationality or
opinions one specific Dimension relates
to individuals who are considered a
security
threat and have received a return
order currently they can be asked to
leave
voluntarily we must urgently change
this and this is the reason why we the
European commission have therefore
proposed that if a person is
considered to be a national security
threat member states must have the power
to force the person to
leave this is in our Asylum and
migration PCT among
others and this is another reason to get
it over the finish line now and I'm very
confident knowing that the next
presidency will be the Belgian
presidency so we will bring this Asylum
and migration pact over the finish line
and on returns we must work more as team
Europe we have more leverage together
the member states and the European
commission we will intensify our efforts
dealing with countries of origin and
Transit we as
Europeans will have to Define who comes
to the European Union and under what
circumstances all this is based on a
comprehensive partnership with countries
of origin and Transit but important is
to work together as team
Europe thank you take a few
questions Minister from Swedish
television tv4 I have a question to you
regarding now you had this terrorist
attack are there any measures that you
will take immediately to make sure that
there is another one and how F will be
able to share an investigation with
SW well first of all we've taken
measures from the moment that uh that we
had seen that there had been an attack
on on Swedish citizens uh we immediately
protected locations in in Belgium which
could be linked to Swedish interest
which is your embassies some of the
retail spaces which are linked to uh to
Sweden um that is still the case and we
will continue doing so until we are in
in certainty that the threat is
completely gone today it looks like the
person was a lone actor um but that in
investigation is still uh is still uh is
still is still going on we are still in
a situation where there is significantly
additional police presence throughout
throughout the country and we will uh we
will continue doing doing so uh the
police investigation is uh is being
shared already and our our our security
services are in contact with the the
Swedish ones uh information is being
shared on on on the past of that uh of
that of that of that person uh we have
strong indications that what happened
was linked to um and and the person had
stated that it's was linked specifically
towards uh towards Swedish Swedish
people and and and so we have done the
analysis that uh additional effort needs
to be needs to be done specifically to
that uh to that uh to that to that topic
look we are um we are Partners in this
in as
Europeans uh this was an attack against
Swedish citizens in Belgium related to a
football game between Belgium and and uh
and and Sweden so this is Europe in
essence and and we know that we have
European citizens from from from all
over living in uh in in Brussels and
it's our full priority to make sure that
they can live here in in security of
course I was wondering your thoughts
about um the failure by the Belgian
government to send the terrorist back to
his uh country of origin although his
Asylum procedure had been finished for
quite some time do you think this could
have been avoided if Belgian authorities
had done a better
job since we have exactly the same
problem in Sweden exactly the same
problem
with very many people who are declined
Asylum uh but refuses to leave the
country that is a that's a big problem
one problem is obvious it it simply
takes away the difference between being
to have the Asylum and to be
declined that is obviously bad but it
also makes it possible for people who
are dangerous uh to stay in your country
and to hide and to to become a Potential
Threat and um since I know how hard this
is and since we have exactly the same
problem I I I don't blame Belgium at all
it's ironic that um this specific
person waiting for the formal
investigation has also been in Sweden um
from time to time and seem to be
convicted in Sweden as well uh and
should have should not have been in
Sweden at all
basically another
question Swedish daily dog NE the gunman
had had claimed asylum in several EU
countries it's for you prime minister de
grow and was denied asylum in Belgium
2020 and how come he could live here
with his family for several years and
was not was not returned to Tunisia and
the second question if I may uh Brussel
Minister for employment claim that this
attack had uh security failures and the
information from the foreign office
wasn't shared with the uh commun
commun to the municipality and to its
local police department what do you say
about this criticism
please first of all um I would like
thank you for uh Mr Christenson what you
what you said we we are both confronted
to the same problem and it's not not
only Sweden and Belgium uh most European
countries are confronted with that with
that issue is that on one side yes we
have international obligations to give
protection to people who deserve
protection and we do and and both our
countries do a tremendous effort in
giving International protection to
people who are entitled so but the flip
side of that of course is that the
people who are not entitled to that
protection should uh should leave the
territory um in this case this person
indeed had received the order to leave
the territory and then then went went
underwater and and was impossible for us
uh to know where our security services
did not did not were not able to monitor
where he uh where he
was indeed he should have left the
territory and there's two ways of doing
that one of them is uh is doing that in
a voluntary way and and as president of
the commission said uh we need as member
states additional tools additional
possibilities to do that it is quite
clear that just gently asking is not
enough at some point as a country you
should be able to say you've asked for
protection you did not receive
protection because the analysis we did
when we tell you to leave you need to
leave that also means that we need
better agreements with a country of
origin because it's easy for some people
to say well just make them
leave but leaving means that the person
needs needs to be accepted in the
country of origin and that is today
often something extremely
complicated we need better agreements on
that and we need more conditionality on
that you know we as a European Union we
are second to none in the Investments we
do in our neighborhood we invest
together with so many countries in for
example our North African neighborhood
but also in the rest of Africa in in in
the Eastern flank and uh and and so on
that investment we do we do because we
believe that if our neighbors do better
it's to the benefit of
everyone but that cannot be
unconditional and we need to come to
better agreements with our neighbors and
that needs to be respectful
agreements um to make sure that everyone
takes this responsibility we need to
take our responsibility on International
protection and we're willing to do so
but it can only work if responsibility
is also being taken on the other side
that when people are not entitled to
protection that uh we have respectful
Humane but also uh binding ways to send
people back from where uh from where
they come we have we are confronted with
that issue and it's uh good to hear dear
that you're confronted the same issue
and you can ask any European leader
leader we're all confronted to that to
that issue on the sharing of uh of uh of
of
information um I have seen that
information has been
shared uh between our Asylum Office and
between the city where the person was
but he was not registered there who was
not in a in a legal way in a legal way
there um the investigation is going on
on on how it is possible that that
information was not digested or was not
being used there is today a lot of
questions and uh I want answer answers
on that question so that I can change
policy may I add to that fully agree may
I add to that uh the need for sharing
information between countries not only
between intelligence agencies but also
the fact that this person the the
suspected person uh had been in prisoned
in Sweden for example that kind of
information could have been useful for
the assessment being made here in in
Belgium so I think there is a huge need
not only for common border control but
also for for common information sharing
to be able to to protect our
societies thank you just one more
question Andreas lad at the Swedish
public radio for both Prime Ministers
ahead of the game on Monday uh there has
there had been a an increased threat
levels against Swedish citizens due to
Coran burnings in Sweden and one could
also add to that the conflict Israel
Hamas who could add tensions as well uh
so given this uh what was this uh taken
into consideration when preparing
organizing the game on Monday what
security measures were in place were
these security measures enough do you
think given what happened uh and um also
from the Swedish authorities to the
Swedish prime minister uh what what kind
of warnings were made to Swedish fans if
I also May to uh commission president um
in I mean there's been this problem with
not returning migrants that have um does
not receive a Asylum it's been a problem
for years and years so in concrete terms
what should really
change
M well first of all um for any
International Event we do a a threat
analysis and we have a lot of
international events happening in in in
Belgium almost every week There's big
international events in a football game
like this is uh is is one of them that
that analysis had been done um in in the
past also on on would there be an impact
on um the the tension that there is in
in Sweden around this this this this
this topic and uh and here in uh in in
in here in
Belgium when two people
die the only thing you can say is that
things have gone wrong and um and uh we
need to look
into what were the outcomes of the
analysis and did the analysis use the
right information from what I base the
analysis was the right one the question
is okay was all the information which
was available used to come to that uh to
that uh to that conclusion obviously a
lot of attention was going to the impact
that the the conflict in uh in Israel
and Palestina what what what the what
the links could have been to uh to that
but in the case of this game with Sweden
we know that there was another element
as well so the the investigation is
going on and we were especially looking
at the factor um was all the information
available being uh being used
well uh since we uh as you know we have
our share of deadly shootings in
Sweden so we know how difficult it is to
to um to find them to prevent it and to
um to do all the necessary uh protection
um being needed uh but what I do say
when we raise the lever from 3 to four
on a 5° scale August 17 I think when the
Swedish Security Police made that
decision it was obviously because they
realized and they
communicated uh the kind of risks that
we are exposed to right now that in
Sweden attacks in Sweden attack on
swedes or on Swedish um Properties or
interest uh abroad uh nobody could
obviously foresee this specific event
brazils and Belgium is
one of the most internationalized part
of the world in Europe so so I mean a
lot of swedes live here a lot of sweds
go here without for good reasons without
fear uh but literally this kind of of
terrorist attack what was what they
actually um meant when they communicated
the the high levels of
risk um yes you asked what um has to
change on return as far as I understand
the terrorist had several Asylum
applications in different member
states um this has already changed in
the last month we have now um a mutual
recognition of return decisions that
means once you apply for Asylum and it
has been rejected and there's a return
decision it is valid in every member
State second then of course is the
operation part so to make sure that the
return happens to the countries of
origin and here um we have seen that too
often each and every member State on its
own has started to negotiate with the
countries of origin and Transit us
together I call it team Europe but it is
the 27 member states and the European
commission we have together much more
leverage um if you look at all the
complex relationship we have with these
countries of origin and transit to uh be
very clear that we want a comprehensive
partnership we want for example to
invest in these countries we are willing
to invest in the educational system but
also in the infrastructure but in return
these countries have to take
responsibility for their own citizens
and this means take them back the third
point where um I think we have to work
on together is uh the operational
procedure so the the physical return to
the country of origin or Transit um that
has to be um where we have to have much
more shared uh operations for example
through a frontex that is a common
European
instrument thank you this concludes our
press
conference thank you thank you thank
you